[Music]
soak in that picture of a not so busy
airport it's not going to look like that
on Memorial Day Weekend there could be
record travel numbers put up so all week
we are sharing tips that could help you
plan for the holiday weekend and other
summer getaways and today only on CBS
mornings we're revealing the best U.S
airlines of 2023 according to the travel
website the points guy coming in at
number five Southwest Airlines put it on
the board number four American Airlines
number three Alaska Airlines number two
United Airlines and in the top spot for
the fifth year in a row Delta Airlines
guy CEO and founder Brian Kelly joins us
now to talk through that list Brian
thank you for being here for having me
Delta number one they're on a streak one
of the factors that go into this list
you know what we look at most is
reliability you know that's something we
can all agree on when you buy an airline
ticket especially an expensive one these
days you at least need to get where
you're going and Delta shines there they
are the best run operationally about 15
years ago they spent billions of dollars
on their Tech stack so their Delta
agents can all speak with each other so
when things do go wrong they know how to
handle it and that's where they shine
now I won't know Delta did drop a couple
points from last year interesting uh but
they are still firmly in in first place
and you said overall Airlines scored
worse why yeah so you know we talk about
in 2022 which is most of this data that
we pulled for this report you know
airfare was up 22 percent which is a lot
but guess what complaints were up nearly
a hundred percent wow you know 25 up
missing bags
um and so overall it was a tough year
for travel and you know the key reason
was last year was a bounce back year
Staffing was low and you know the big
issue with flight delays and
cancellations is air traffic in New York
City this summer we're canceling flights
out of New York City because there are
not enough air traffic controllers it's
not quite a crisis but we've seen a lot
of near-misses of planes landing this is
an issue our government has to make a
priority the other thing that uh
Travelers care about price and prices
are going up even though some of the
things that we worry about lost bags
timing they're not so great absolutely
and that's the one category where Delta
was the worst in price and it's that old
adage you get what you pay for but there
are still a lot of airlines that do
offer affordable affordability but you
got to look at the big picture when
traveling and we also factored in
loyalty where the Points Guy so does the
airline offer good value back and then
also the experience you know JetBlue has
been offering free Wi-Fi for years Delta
just announced it so we wanted to take
in all of these different things in
determining which airline shines the
most I do like a free Wi-Fi situation
that's great uh okay traveling with
young children as I do you've got a
seven month old Dean congratulations on
fatherhood there
um what are the airlines best for
families particularly with little little
ones well luckily there's been some
positivity there so you know it's crazy
to think there's no law that states that
your children have to travel with you
even if four we've we've heard stories
of four-year-olds getting separated from
their parents on flights and then the
airline agents saying well it's your
fault right that's the first number you
have to pay a hundred dollars to sit
with your child so uh last year
President Biden the State of the Union
warned the airlines hey you better get
your act together or else we'll do it
for you and shockingly within a couple
weeks the airline started to come out
United Airlines has led the pack there
kids 14 and under now will be able to
sit regardless of fair class American
just came out Frontier there's still no
passenger Bill of Rights though in the
U.S and I really do think we need that
you know when Airlines cancel flights
and having these basic rules of
engagement that the airlines should
abide by so one thing uh you've got a
passport for yourself a month old I got
a passport for our little Celine she's
going to be traveling internationally
when she's about six months what are the
things people it's really hard to get a
passport for a child a baby it is I mean
my biggest thing I took my my baby into
the post office to get the picture don't
do that because he was his bobble head
was squirming around it was okay
we took a picture
I I don't know that's the lane that's
how we took her picture yeah on a white
blanket yeah print it put the picture at
home but everyone and whether you have a
password or not every single person
right now I want you to check your
passport expiration and if it's coming
up on six months just send it in for
Renewal now
um and when you get your password so you
can pay for expedited in my case that
was three weeks I got it but it's now up
to five six seven here's another tip
contact your local Congress person's
office they have Congressional Liaisons
they'll Fast Track IT Ryan Kelly as
always we thank you my friends